then you'll turn your video I hope it  takes you back to that place  Taylor Swift is taking it back to her  country roots music is something I need  so it's always my number one priority  [Music]  the pop star surprise fans at her  reputation tour stop in Nashville  performing her debut single Tim McGraw  with the song's namesake and his wife  Faith Hill  [Applause]  [Music]  [Applause]  [Music]  before the iconic trio took to the stage  Tim shared shots of the group goofing  around during sound check and appearing  to have a blast they thank T Swift after  the concert writing on Instagram quote  your show was absolutely magical and Tim  shared the same sentiments adding quote  man how cool can it be for a guy thanks  Taylor for having us on your stage we  had a blast it's a lot of fun we have so  much fun  [Music]  [Applause]